hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to deep dive into
what jenkins is and how it improves your
devops continuous integration
environments
so this is what we're going to be
covering in this session we're going to
cover what life is like before using
jenkins and the issues that jenkins
specifically addresses then we'll get
into what jenkins is about and how it
applies to continuous integration and
the other continuous integration tools
that you need in your devops team then
specifically we'll deep dive into
features of jenkins and the jenkins
architecture and we'll give you a case
study of a company that's using jenkins
today to actually transform how their it
organization is operating so let's talk
a little bit about life before jenkins
let's see this scenario i think it's
something that maybe all of you can
relate to as developers we all write
code and we all submit that code into a
code repository and we all keep working
away writing our unit tests and
hopefully we're running our unit tests
but the problem is that the actual
commits that actually gets sent to the
code repository aren't consistent you as
a developer may be based in india you
may have another developer that's based
in the philippines and you may have
another team lead that's based in the uk
and another development team that's
based in north america so you're all
working at different times and you have
different amounts of code going into the
code repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we like to call
development hell where things just
aren't working out and there's just lots
of delays being added into the project
and the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with just
a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other
so let's jump into jenkins and see what
jenkins is and how it can address these
problems
so jenkins is a product that comes out
of the concept of continuous integration
that you may have heard of as power
developers where you'd have two
developers sitting next to each other
coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment
so there are two ways in which you can
do continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous so
the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
legacy approach to building out
solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created and that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of that code in an arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification services into the build
environment so you're always running
cycles to test against your code
this is the power that jenkins provides
in continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created
now if on the continuous integration
server a test isn't passed then that
code gets sent back to the developer and
the developer can then make the changes
it allows the developer to actually do a
couple of things it allows the developer
not to break the build and we all don't
want to break the builds that are being
created but it also allows the developer
not to actually have to run all the
tests locally on their computer right
tests particularly if you have a large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service up
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be beyond just the standard ci test
so maybe there's a code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it
simply just works
so let's talk a little bit about some of
the tools that you may have in your
continuous integration environment so
the cool thing with working with
continuous integration tools is that
they are all open source at least the
ones that we have listed here are open
source there are some that are private
but typically you'll get started with
open source tools and it gives you the
opportunity to understand how you can
accelerate your environment quickly so
bamboo is a continuous integration tool
that specifically runs multiple builds
in parallel for faster compilation so if
you have multiple versions of your
software that runs on multiple platforms
this is a tool that really allows you to
get that up and running super fast so
that your teams can actually test how
those different builds would work for
different environments and this has
integration with and maven and other
similar tools so one of the tools you're
going to need is a tool that allows you
to automate the software build test and
release process and buildbot is that
open source product for you again it's
an open source tool so there's no
license associated with this so you can
actually go in and you can actually get
the environment up and running and you
can then test for and build your
environment and create your releases
very quickly so buildbots also written
in python and it does support parallel
execution jobs across multiple platforms
if you're working specifically on java
projects that need to be built and test
then apache gump is the tool for you it
makes all of those projects really easy
it makes all the java projects easier
for you to be able to test with api
level and functionality level testing so
one of the popular places to actually
store code and create a versioning of
your code is github and it's a service
that's available on the web just
recently acquired by microsoft if you
are storing your projects in github then
you'll be able to use travis continuous
integration of travis ci and it's a tool
designed specifically for hosted github
projects
and so finally we're covering jenkins
and jenkins is a central tool for
automation for all of your projects now
when you're working with jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called hudson hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became jenkins and it was
acquired by oracle when that acquisition
happened the team behind um hudson was a
little concerned about the direction
that oracle may potentially go with
hudson and so they created a hard fork
of hudson that they renamed jenkins and
jenkins has now become that open source
project it is one of the most popular
and continuously contributed projects
that's available as open source so
you're always getting new features being
added to it it's a tool that really
becomes the center for your ci
environment
so let's jump into some of those really
great features that are available in
jenkins so jenkins itself is really
comprised of five key areas around easy
installation easy configuration plugins
extensibility and distribution so as i
mentioned for the easy installation
jenkins is a self-contained java program
and that allows it to run on most
popular operating systems including
windows mac os and unix you even run it
on linux
it really isn't too bad to set up it
used to be much harder than it is today
the setup process has really improved
the web interface makes it really easy
for you to check for any errors in
addition you have great built-in help
one of the things that makes tools like
jenkins really powerful for developers
and continuous integration teams and
your devops teams as a whole when you
have plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly check it out
there's just lots of stuff out there
in addition to the plug-in architecture
jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure jenkins to fit in your
environment it's almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending jenkins not creating a
custom version of jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
foundation remains as the core jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core foundation the
distribution and the nature of jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your ci environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the jenkins
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing at least you
should be doing you're committing your
code to a git server um or to an svn
server or a similar type of service so
in this instance you'll be using jenkins
as the place for you to commit your code
jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the jenkins environment assuming
everything passed the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
jenkins and finally again ready to
deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or go
through a nightly build you're looking
at being able to commit your code and go
through this testing process and release
process continuously as an example
companies etsy will release up to 50
different versions of their website
every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within jenkins that allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections on the left hand side
of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and will
run tests against it it will use a build
server such as maven to actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that feedback is sent right
back to the developers so that they can
then change their code so that the build
environment can run effectively
the final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
groups can be written in selenium so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how jenkins can be
extended with plug-ins mavin and
selenium are just two very popular
examples of how you can extend the
jenkins environment the goal to go
through this whole process again is an
automated process is to get your code
from the developer to the production
server as quickly as possible have it
fully tested and have no errors so it's
probably important at this point to
mention
one piece of information around the
jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of jenkins for that to be able
to happen
so let's talk a little bit about the
master slave architecture within jenkins
so what we have here is an overview of
the master slave architecture within
jenkins on the left-hand side is the
remote source code repository and that
remote source code repository could be
github or it could be
team foundation services or the new
azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that master
environment can then push out to
multiple other jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario over the
last 10 or 15 years there has been a
significant shift within the automotive
industry where manufacturers have
shifted from creating complex hardware
to actually creating software we've seen
that with companies such as tesla
where they are creating uh software to
manage their cars we see the same thing
with companies such as general motors
with their onstar program and ford just
recently have rebranded themselves as a
technology company rather than just a
automotive company what this means
though is that the software within these
cars is becoming more complex and
requires more testing to allow more
capabilities enhancements to be added to
the core software so bosch is a company
that specifically ran into this problem
and their challenge was that they wanted
to be able to streamline the
increasingly complex automotive software
by adopting continuous integration and
continuous delivery best practices with
the goal of being able to delight and
exceed the customer expectations of the
end user so bosch has actually used
cloudbees which is the enterprise
jenkins environment so to be able to
reduce them the number of manual steps
such as building deploying and testing
bosch has introduced the use of cloud bs
from jenkins and this is part of the
enterprise jenkins platform has
significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software development cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment
now the results have been tangible
previously it took three days before a
build process could be done and now it's
taken that same three-day process and
reduced it to less than three hours that
is significant large-scale deployments
are now kept on track and have expert
support and there is clear visibility
and transparency across the whole
operations through using the jenkins
tools
so some key takeaways from this
presentations first of all we describe
the developer hell that you may be in
before the use of jenkins and then we
talked about what the difference is
between a nightly build and a continuous
delivery continuous integration
environment can look like we step
through how a continuous integration
environment should be set up so it's
constantly providing feedback to the
developer or to the tester to improve
and speed up the efficiency of
delivering code that gets delivered out
to the end user we went specifically
through the process that jenkins uses
and the jenkins pipeline and then
stepped through the architecture that
jenkins employs to be successful in
enabling you as a developer to build not
just one but maybe multiple platform
solutions at once and then finally we
step through a use case study around the
work that bosch is doing to be able to
significantly improve the efficiency of
the software that they are delivering
into the automotive industry really hope
that you've enjoyed this presentation if
you like it please hit subscribe and the
notification button below and you'll
always be kept up to date on new videos
that we are producing if you have any
ideas or comments please stick them
below and we'll have somebody from the
team answer your specific questions
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here